and tonight I asked you to give me what
forty-three governors already have
give me a line-item veto this year
generations of presidents wanted a
line-item veto
none had until the Clinton
administration when Congress passed the
line-item veto Act of 1996 Clinton used
it 82 times before the Supreme Court
ruled it unconstitutional two years
later
that didn't stop future presidents from
wanting it I think there's not a
president out there that wouldn't love
to have it including president Trump who
was clearly frustrated at the Democratic
leverage in the omnibus spending bill
while that bill gave him defense
spending it gave them domestic spending
and it gave taxpayers more deficit
spending I'm calling on Congress to give
me a line-item veto for all government
spending bills Treasury secretary Steve
minuchin repeated the president's call
on Sunday paying no heed to its
unconstitutionality
I think they should give the president a
line-item veto these things
unconstitutional by the Supreme Court
sir well again Congress could pass a
rule okay that allows them to do it but
it would take a constitutional amendment
not just a rule Congress tried it in
2011 after the High Court ruling it
ticker dwith a more moderate version of
a line-item veto that attempted to
maintain the balance of power the
president would propose cuts and then
Congress would have to approve those
cuts so the president couldn't go in and
just strike everything that he wanted
out that bill ultimately died in the
Senate so where does that leave
President Trump he wants to fix the
budget process and his message to
leaders in Congress of both parties is
that if something similar happens again
he's much more inclined to veto it so
look out for September 30th that's the
date that the current funding bill runs
out and the process then begins all over
again with the new impediment the
midterm elections just six weeks away